before the pandemic the number of people
in poverty had been steadily falling for
years now it's rising again for the
first time since 1998 that's because all
over the world most people cannot go to
work and that's particularly difficult
for people in poorer countries and
migrant workers to make it worse food
prices are going up there are major
disruptions to supply and without
laborers crops are being left to rot in
the fields from the u.s. to India to the
Philippines King's College London
estimates the number of extremely poor
people globally could increase by 420
million over the next several months
less speak now to jayati Ghosh in New
Delhi she's the chairwoman of the center
for economic studies and planning at the
Jawaharlal Nehru University giotto Ghosh
welcome to the NewsHour are we talking
here just to be clear about people
actually tipping over into what you
would label as being starvation extreme
destitution in India for example what we
call a war is actually what in any other
country would be called extreme
destitution that people who cannot
afford to eat in us and we estimate that
that number would have at least doubled
at the very least okay so people need
food as quickly as possible but they
also need cash transfers as well I guess
because local economies micro economies
they have ceased to exist they've gone
and they're probably not coming back
that's right yes it's a very real
concern you see because it's certainly
been a major major efforts on the food
front because there's going to be
massive increases in hunger but right
now the big concern is to shift people's
purchasing power to give them something
to make up for the loss of livelihood of
the last two months immediate cash
transfers for about three months to the
informal workers were all lost wages
lost livelihoods and immediate efforts
to make sure that the minimum that they
need for survival is available
okay you're talking about big cash
transfers if you look at a country like
India you're talking as well about a
sizable percentage of the population who
don't have a bank account how do you do
that securely and how do you trust
everyone in the chain between a bank
handing out cash and people getting the
cash perhaps hundreds of miles away well
ingenuity you can of course - bank
transfers where you can access the bank
people but there are many innovative
ways that state governments have thought
of in Orissa pension payments are
distributed in public every week in
front of everyone and there's a system
of indelible ink to ensure that those
cannot come and people cannot come and
get it twice so you have to actually
realize because we are in a time of
extreme emergency we cannot just depend
on the existing structures they won't be
inadequate so we have to think of
innovative ways many of the local
governments have actually worked out
ways of doing this but we need to have a
central government that has the vision
to actually go out there and spend this
money
immediately we need TT 3% of GDP is
spent on just providing this basic
income for a few months is the federal
government doing this to any degree at
all as of now no unfortunately that's
the shocking thing the central
government has been completely inactive
on this the amount of fiscal stimulus
that has been provided is less than one
percent of GDP and it's really not
reaching the people we have seen such
extreme cases of humanitarian
catastrophe and tragedy migrant workers
chatting for hundreds of miles
children dying on the roads women giving
birth on the roadside as they try and
travel back to their homes to face
starvation even their I mean we have
seen incredible humanitarian tragedies
and we need to do something urgently if
you get this if the federal government
if the national government Narendra
Modi's government does something
approaching this across the country so
it's not just down to individual states
how long is long enough to begin to
scratch the surface so people have
enough food to eat to stay alive they
have enough cash in the bank or not in
the bank in their pockets to buy food I
mean are we talking about a month
or six months or a year but first of all
you see food we already have a
functioning public food distribution
system the government is sitting on 50
million tons extra surplus food stocks
which they should just distribute
immediately for free Jen kilograms with
a person per month it can be done the
infrastructure is there you just have to
make the food available no one can
understand we're not doing that that
should be done for six months I would
say the free food because we have enough
stops it's all lying there
these are surplus stocks the cash
transfers I would say three months and
then move into the food for one program
or a food and employment program the
already have a Rural Employment
Guarantee I would say we make that
something Universal offer it to every
adult not a hundred days per household
but maybe 200 days and extend that to
urban areas as well because initially we
need to give them food and some basic
income but eventually we should go up to
an employment can't
does this chime with the similar
situations that we see in countries like
South Sudan countries like Yemen where
you know we report on this channel a lot
on what's going on in the Yemeni
conflict and for a good two years now
we've been saying the countries on the
brink of starvation it already had an
issue with cholera I can't imagine that
it would be easier for the Yemeni
administration's to bring in the kind of
system that you're talking about
compared to India no I think that Yemen
is in fact a particular tragedy because
it's also been ravaged by conflict by
war and by all of the other diseases
that you've mentioned in a situation of
extreme poverty and fertility and so he
has many of the existing structures I
don't exist and we have to be created
but nonetheless there is scope for
immediate provision of cash at least to
enable people to use the market to buy
the essentials if nothing else okay we
have to leave it there giant egos thank
you so much for your time